lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
darles una noción de lo que trata las
cuentas de ahorro para el retiro con la
modalidad de arroz
y para darles una idea de por qué se
llaman rock es una modalidad creada por
este congresista de eeuu llamado william
rock que fue quien propuso esta
modalidad un senador del estado de
delaware en estados unidos
y esta modalidad fue aprobada en el año
de 1997 así que por eso fue nombrada en
su honor pero regresando al tema es un
tipo especial de cuenta de ahorro para
el retiro individual y vamos a ver de
qué se trata así que vamos a comparar
las cuentas de ahorros en la modalidad
tradicional
y las vamos a comparar con las cuentas
de ahorro para el retiro de ross y más
adelante veremos un ejemplo con números
para entender cuál es la diferencia
entre estas la primera pregunta es qué
sucede cuando ingresamos dinero en
nuestra cuenta de ahorros para el retiro
aquí vamos a ver la parte de impuestos
en el vídeo sobre cuentas de ahorro para
el retiro tradicional vimos que los
impuestos se difieren son diferidos
diferidos
es decir no se van a cobrar impuestos en
ese momento de ese dinero si yo fuera a
poner cinco mil dólares en esta cuenta
de ahorros no me cobraría ningún
impuesto por ello sin embargo en la
modalidad de arroz no se difieren los
impuestos tengo que pagar impuestos por
esa cantidad así que aquí son
diferidos
así que tengo que pagar impuestos por
esos 5000 dólares que yo fuera a
ingresar a esta cuenta y bueno de entrar
a esto podríamos decir pues no nos
parece tan bueno pues tengo que pagar
impuestos por esto en esta modalidad
cuando en esta no tengo que pagar nada
pero ya veremos en un momento cuál es la
cuestión interesante aquí otra
característica es que siempre y cuando
el capital o el dinero que yo ingresé
nunca salga de esa cuenta se mantenga en
nuestra cuenta de ahorros para el retiro
en ambas modalidades las ganancias no
tendrán impuestos ganancias
libres
de impuestos
y esto aplica en ambas modalidades
y bueno ustedes me pueden decir ok pues
está bien que no pague impuestos por las
ganancias pero de todas maneras esta
parte de tener que pagar impuestos acá
pues tampoco me sigue gustando tengan
paciencia ahorita les voy a explicar qué
pasa aquí eso si las ganancias o libres
de impuestos mientras se mantengan en la
cuenta importante mientras se mantengan
en la cuenta de ahorro para el retiro ya
vimos que aquí tengo que pagar impuestos
aquí no tengo que pagar impuestos en el
dinero que ingreso y en ambas puedo
invertir ese dinero comprar acciones
comprar bonos de manera que ese dinero
pueda recibir algún interés o alguna
ganancia y de esas ganancias no me van a
cobrar impuestos siempre y cuando las
mantenga en la cuenta de ahorros aquí lo
interesante viene cuando tengo que
retirar dinero de esta cuenta y hay
muchas restricciones para que yo pueda
retirar dinero de esas cuentas de ahorro
para el retiro pero no entraremos en
detalle de estas restricciones solo la
esencia de esta modalidad de cuentas ros
digamos que ya soy mayor de los 59 y
medio años mi dinero aquí en la cuenta
rosa ha estado durante 5 años así que
digamos que ahora ya puedo retirar pues
soy mayor de 59 años y medio y ahora si
quiero hacer un retiro retiro ya que
tengo esta edad en las cuentas de ahorro
para el retiro tradicionales tengo que
pagar impuestos al retirar el dinero
pagar impuestos
al retirarlo y tengo que pagar impuestos
por toda la cantidad que esté retirando
y es el pago de impuestos de ingresos
ordinarios
ingresos ordinarios
pero cuando hago este retiro en la
cuenta arroz aquí no pagó impuestos no
hay impuestos que pagar esto está más
interesante en el vídeo anterior
habíamos comentado que en estas cuentas
de ahorros tradicionales no está tan mal
el pago de sus impuestos ya que para
esta edad el tabulador en el que nos
encontramos ya que no estamos recibiendo
tantos ingresos como cuando éramos más
jóvenes el tabulador es más pequeño
entonces hay que pagar menos impuestos y
este pago de impuestos ha sido diferido
durante bastantes años todo el tiempo
que yo haya dejado este dinero en la
cuenta antes de retirarlo y esa parte
está interesante porque cuando yo
ingresé al dinero en esta cuenta tipo
rosa pague impuestos sobre la cantidad
original que ingresé sin embargo durante
el tiempo que estuvo ese dinero en la
cuenta se pudo haber invertido en
comprar acciones en comprar bonos y haya
aumentado ese dinero que invertir así
que cuando voy a retirarlo no voy a
tener que pagar impuestos y va a ser una
cantidad bastante mayor que la cantidad
original así después de todo ese tiempo
que creció este capital que yo invertí
aquí pues no tengo que pagar ningún
interés y eso ya suena bastante mejor
así que esto es bastante bueno y después
veremos un ejemplo con números para que
veamos cuál es el impacto de esta
característica otra cosa interesante con
respecto a esta modalidad de cuentas de
ahorros es que si yo voy a hacer un
retiro anticipado es decir un retiro
antes de esta edad retiro
anticipado
para el cierre tradicional voy a tener
que pagar un 10% de penalización sobre
todo el dinero que yo voy a retirar más
los impuestos correspondientes más
impuestos en el cierre ros si yo tengo
una cantidad original que invertí y eso
lo vamos a ver con un ejemplo numérico
para que quede más claro si yo retiro
esa cantidad principal con la que yo
comencé esta cuenta de ahorros no tendré
que pagar mi penalización ni impuestos
así que va a haber no penalización no
impuestos
siempre y cuando la cantidad que retire
sea menor o igual a la cantidad original
que invertí
o que ingresé a esta cuenta
y tendré que pagar aunque no sea un
retiro calificado hay diferentes
circunstancias en las que se determina
si un retiro es calificado o no y no
entraré en los detalles de estas
características sólo tendrá que pagar el
10% de penalización en este caso e
impuestos si yo llego a retirar de las
ganancias impuestos en ganancias no en
la cantidad original que invertí sino en
las ganancias que produjo durante este
tiempo que estuvo invertido en esta
cuenta de ahorros una de las razones
principales por las que no entró en
detalle sobre qué características me
permiten calificar un retiro es primero
porque este vídeo sería demasiado
confuso pero también porque el gobierno
de eeuu cambia estas características
cada año y realmente quiero que este
vídeo lo puedan ver dentro de mucho
tiempo en el futuro y siga siendo
vigente por lo que no quiero mencionar
todas las cosas que el gobierno puede
estar cambiando año con año ahora
hagamos una muy básico para comprender
bien todas estas características así que
tenemos una cuenta
de ahorro para el retiro
tradicional
y una cuenta de ahorros para el retiro
ross
y digamos que yo gano más de cinco mil
dólares y de hecho aquí en esta
modalidad de arroz hay ciertas
limitantes sobre la cantidad de dinero
que yo puedo ingresar a esta cuenta
dependiendo de la cantidad total de
ingresos que tenga y nuevamente esto
cambia año con año así que no voy a
mencionar detalles ya que ustedes pueden
buscar estos detalles por su cuenta y de
hecho hay maneras en las que se puede
transferir dinero de una era tradicional
a una cr rosa así que hay varias maneras
de darle la vuelta a esas restricciones
solo recuerden que en estas sea el arroz
hay más limitaciones sobre la cantidad
de dinero ingresar entonces digamos que
voy a ingresar en mi cuenta
5000 dólares en la cr tradicional mis
impuestos mis impuestos son cero no
tengo que pagar nada de impuestos en el
sea el arroz aquí inicialmente digamos
que yo estoy en un tabulador
de impuestos del 32% como lo vimos en el
vídeo anterior
y tenemos que pagar el 32% de 5000
dólares sacamos la calculadora y tenemos
punto 32 por 5 mil dólares y nos da 1600
dólares de impuestos y aquí tendré que
pagar
1.600 dólares de impuestos así pues el
capital principal o el ingreso principal
en mis cuentas será en la tradicional
pues de cinco mil dólares ya que no tuve
que quitarle nada de impuestos y en la
modalidad de ross como tuve que quitar
1600 por impuestos sólo me va a quedar
5000 menos 1600 que van a ser 3.400
dólares y en ambos casos digamos que
tomamos nuestro dinero y lo invertimos
no sé en algunas acciones
y resulta que este dinero en ambos casos
se duplica así que aquí al duplicar 5000
tendré 10.000
a duplicar 3.400 tendremos 6 mil 800 y
esto es después de 5 años así que este
dinero lo invertir a lo mejor compre
acciones o bonos pasaron 5 años en ambos
casos y este dinero se duplicó y digamos
que después de estos 5 años aún no
tenemos la edad de 59 y medio años
podríamos dejar estas cantidades que
sigan en la cuenta hasta que tengamos
esta edad establecida pero digamos que
antes de esa fecha tuvimos alguna
urgencia una necesidad de sacar el
dinero de estas cuentas así que
analicemos la situación en la que
tenemos que retirar antes de que
tengamos la edad requerida así que aquí
va a ser un retiro retiro y vamos a
imaginar que tenemos que retirar
3.400 dólares
y queremos hacer este retiro en nuestra
cuenta tradicional vamos a tener que
hacer dos cosas primero vamos a tener
que pagar impuestos de esta cantidad así
que tendríamos que pagar el 32% de esto
suponiendo que nos encontramos todavía
en este mismo tabulador de impuestos
tenemos tres mil cuatrocientos
por punto 32
nos da mil 88 así que aquí tendremos que
pagar de impuestos mil 88 dólares
de impuestos
y también tendremos que pagar una
penalización de toda esta cantidad así
que no está penalización es el 10% de
esto por lo que tendremos que pagar
340 por penalización
y lo que vamos a tener después de quitar
todo esto sacamos la calculadora de las
1400 menos mil 88 menos 340 por lo que
finalmente después de los impuestos y la
penalización sólo tendremos mil
972 dólares como efectivo en el caso de
la modalidad de rock como sólo quiero
sacar
3.400 que es una cantidad de menor o
igual a la cantidad que ingresen
originalmente a mi cantidad principal no
voy a tener que pagar ni impuestos ni
penalización así que podré sacar por
completo los
3.400 dólares así que en cualquier
momento del tiempo en el que yo quiera
retirar el error siempre y cuando esa
cantidad sea menor o igual a la cantidad
original o principal que ingresé no voy
a tener que pagar ni impuestos ni
penalización y ya vimos que en la
tradicional cuando yo quiero retirar
antes de tiempo voy a tener que pagar
impuestos y penalización por lo estas
cuentas de rock nos dan bastante
flexibilidad en estos casos ahora
supongamos otro caso en el que tengo que
retirar de en cuatro mil dólares en este
mismo momento del tiempo en este
escenario de la cea r tradicional
nuevamente si queremos retirar 4000
vamos a tener que pagar impuestos el 32
por ciento de esto y la penalización que
es el 10 por ciento será 4 mil x
el 32% en impuestos
más la penalización de 400 dólares
esto es por la penalización de sacarlo
antes de tiempo
y aquí él hace a herederos por la
cantidad principal los 3400 que
invertirá originalmente no voy a tener
que pagar nada y por la diferencia de
esta cantidad y lo que quiero sacar
completo que son aquí nada más 600
dólares por este es el que voy a tener
que pagar impuestos y penalización pero
nada más por esta diferencia así que por
estos 600 dólares tengo que pagar el 32
por ciento de impuestos más
60 dólares de penalización
el 10% de esto y esto solo es de la
parte correspondiente de las ganancias
que estoy retirando como vimos la
cantidad de principal se retira sin
ningún impuesto ni penalización esta es
una situación mucho mejor comparada con
esta así que en general si ustedes si
ustedes sospechan que van a tener que
usar este dinero en el futuro pues les
convendría mucho más invertirlo en una
cuenta de ahorros de rock ya que les
proporciona más flexibilidad y ahora
veamos el caso en el que llegamos a la
edad en que podemos hacer el retiro del
dinero supongamos que nunca sacamos este
dinero nunca hicimos un retiro antes de
tiempo y ese dinero pues lo seguimos
invirtiendo aquí lo seguimos invirtiendo
y éste también y después de otros cinco
años se duplicó esta cantidad así que
aquí tengo 20 mil dólares y en este caso
tengo 13 mil 600 dólares
y en estas dos situaciones es muy bueno
que podamos hacer inversiones con el
dinero que tenemos en estas cuentas sin
tener que pagar impuestos si no
estuviera este dinero en estas cuentas
cada que hiciéramos alguna compra o
venta para inversión tendríamos que
pagar impuestos en las ganancias del
capital como lo vimos en el vídeo
anterior así que ya tenemos no sé de
edad 60 años y ahora sí vamos a retirar
el dinero de estas cuentas y recordemos
que hay ciertas estipulaciones de un
tiempo mínimo en el que se tiene que
tener este dinero en las cuentas pero
veremos qué sucede cuando retiramos el
dinero a partir de la edad permitida a
esta edad estamos con el tabulador de
impuestos el tabulador de impuestos
del 25 por ciento a diferencia del que
teníamos hace 10 años que era del 32 por
ciento estamos retirados recibimos un
poco menos de dinero como ingreso y por
eso es que tenemos un tabulador de
impuestos menor cuando yo retiro esta
cantidad de mi cuenta de ahorros
tradicional voy a tener que pagar cinco
mil dólares
de impuestos
ya que es el 25% mi tabulador y nos
quedará
15.000 dólares como efectivo para gastar
en lo que necesitemos ya que estamos
retirados y en las cuentas de ahorros
para el retiro de arroz cuando ya tengo
esta edad no importa que tabulador de
impuestos tenga ya que no voy a pagar
impuestos por ello voy a retirar
totalmente la cantidad que tengo
se va directo sin ningún otro trámite
los
13.600 que tengo
así que finalmente vemos que pues bueno
al inicio sí tuvimos que pagar impuestos
en esta modalidad pero solo de la
cantidad de ingresada durante todos los
diez años que estuvo aquí y todo el
dinero que obtuvo de ganancia aquí ya al
final no tuve que pagar ningún impuesto
por ello y además tuve el beneficio de
poderlo sacar antes de tiempo si es una
cantidad menor a la cantidad principal
la pude sacar sin impuestos y sin
penalización y si es mayor a la cantidad
principal sólo tuve que pagar los
impuestos y la penalización de la
cantidad correspondiente a las ganancias
no a la cantidad principal en cambio
aquí cuando tuve que retirar antes de la
fecha permitida tuve que pagar impuestos
y penalización de todo y al final ya
cuando llegue a la edad correspondiente
tuve que pagar impuestos por todo el
dinero que saqué así que bueno aquí
están estas diferencias ya vimos que
esta es más flexible y tiene sus
beneficios particulares y bueno aquí en
nuevos casos yo inventé las cantidades
para que dieran cantidades semejantes al
final sin embargo esto depende de cuál
haya sido el tabulador de impuestos al
inicio dependiendo de sus ingresos y
esto haría que una sea mejor que la otra
o viceversa y estas son consideraciones
importantes sin embargo aquí yo lo que
quería es mostrarles cuál es la esencia
de esta modalidad road en las cuentas de
ahorro para el retiro esta modalidad es
buena en cuanto a que les da
flexibilidad para retirar dinero antes
de tiempo y también pues de que ya no
tienen que preocuparse de pagar
impuestos nunca más al menos en esta
cuenta y otra cosa más que bueno podría
ser positiva dependiendo de su punto de
vista en la modalidad tradicional cuando
se llega a los 70 años y medio se tiene
que retirar el dinero forzosamente así
que es un retiro del dinero
forzoso
y a partir de esta edad pues bueno al
hacer este retiro se tiene que estar
pagando impuestos sin embargo en la
modalidad rock aquí no hay límite de
edad para el retiro no hay límite
así que esta es otra consideración que
vale la pena tener en mente